well the US has role in the Middle East
the global role and the world the
Western society are a system of values
is today under a major attack by
religious fanatics from from
unfortunately the Middle East and the
u.s. is leading the world for the
children of all of us in trying to
confront this terror and try to bring
about a better situation for for the
future generations so the u.s. is as we
see it is active and we are trying to be
as loyal partners as possible in war
against terror in different fronts
trying to see to it that terrorists
don't find safe havens in different
places that we have better intelligence
and gaining incorporation to make sure
that if we can find terrorists before
the attack that we will find them before
they find us we cooperate on different
levels in the area of counterterrorism
from offense to defense at the same time
we are trying with the United States to
see if the reason opportunity to work
with moderates in the Middle East to try
to confront these trends of extremism
and religious fanaticism something that
is more reasonable there is a more
appreciative of the very universal human
values that we all believe in beat the
sanctity of human lives or basic human
rights through every individual and
respect for the other and a piece so
while fighting a very difficult war
against terror at the same time in the
US with Israel or trying to look for
every opportunity to advance peace in
the region and hopefully in the world
we're first of all the United States as
we all know has been attacked from this
region the United States did not wake up
one morning and decided to become
aggressive the United States was
severely attacked by terrorists who used
the societies in this region the
acquiescence of regimes in this region
in order to come and attack America in
the most profound way in my view the
United States is acting in most
legitimate self-defense at the same time
I think that the United States and we
adore the United States for that and we
do the American people for that are not
only looking at their responsibility for
the United States itself they see
themselves as leaders in this world to
assure progress for all not only for the
United States and to defend others from
aggression if we were to think in a
world with these fanatics with these
terrorists without a country like the
United States that is ready sustained
for values and ready to stand for the
good of the world beyond the boundaries
of America we would have been in a very
very troubling if not more than that
world so first to your first question I
think that every citizen of this world
should be thankful to America for what
America is what America stands for and
the readiness of Americans to to pay
with their lives in order to protect not
only America but protect at the same
time the world
Oh